let's get more now from our defense and
security analyst professor michael clark
is back with us
professor thank you so much for coming
in and talking us through this svera
donetsk why is it so important yes
kimberly it's important because the
russians put so much into it it's the
last real city in luhansk and the
russians want the whole of the donbass
so they've got to take luhansk which is
the smaller of the two oblasts in in
that area they uh have got moses vera
done yes now it looks as if the
ukrainians have been pushed back to the
west of the city against the river into
the industrial area where interestingly
there are tunnels and nuclear bunkers as
there was at the avistyle steel works
and we'll see if they make use of that
or whether they withdraw in good order
to liciansk on the other side of the
river where they can hold up the russian
advance by and large the russians are
north and east of the river the ceviesco
donate river the ukrainians are south
and west of the river
and the river is quite an obstacle
nobody actually wants to be the first to
have to try to cross the river the
russians have tried twice made a
complete hash of it lost a lot of people
they've still got to get across the
river in force to continue this advance
they would hope towards slavians and
cremators why is it so hard to get
across the river
dangerous that's all the crossing river
means you're very vulnerable and if the
other side sees you do it or try to do
it then they can target it with
artillery and so on that's what happened
last time okay let's talk about
artillery because we've just said the
kremlin saying that the us by sending
them specific weapons they're just
adding fuel to the fire what are those
weapons yes this the big photograph on
the left here this is the m142 which is
a multiple launch rocket system it's
very good system very flexible extremely
accurate
it carries six missiles and they've got
a range of about 45 miles
um it's not the biggest range weapon but
it's probably the most useful for the
ukrainians at the moment it contrasts
with the the russian systems the
russians have got the grad system again
a range of about 25 uh of 30 miles the
old grad system the one at the top here
is an old cold war system very
inaccurate down here the smersh uh much
more modern russian system about the
same as the uh m142 um but not nearly as
accurate and so when we think about
weapon systems we often talk about game
changers but if the ukrainians get
enough of these soon enough they will be
a game changer because they can compete
with russian artillery which is the
russian strong suit the russians are
really good with artillery they use it
an awful lot if the ukrainians can
outrange them keep their their artillery
away
then they their other virtues where
their military virtues can come through
and they have a real chance then of of
fighting the russians to a standstill
okay let's go back to the actual
fighting on the ground in the south
around her son what is happening there
yes um the uh ukrainians have mounted
quite a big counter-attack um and what
they're trying to do to the northeast of
kirshen and in the last day they've
taken uh or punched through three places
at uh sundarifka a daffodil bridge and a
vasocon vice copelia which i'd never
heard of until yesterday
but looking at that um uh front that's
about a 50-mile front
and so it's interesting that the
ukrainians are trying to threaten
russian communications to kirchen
they're trying to cut off the russian
incursion
and they're behaving like a western army
where's the the russians are going bite
and hold in very small sections the
ukrainians are behave they're doing it
the way we would do it which is to try
to punch through in very quick
offensives at key strategic places
they're doing pretty well at the moment
see how they get on this is only the
beginning of what they would intend and
we'll see how the russians react if
their communication lines start to be
threatened